all right welcome everybody for anybody
who has not uh met me yet I am Dominic
torno I'm a principal engineer here at
tempura
and uh today this last presentation we
want to talk about building event driven
reactive applications with temporal and
the subtitle is workflows versus sagas
epic showdown
so when we talk about event driven and
reactive applications we run into an
issue that we run into in the context of
software engineering all the time and
that is you ask three people and you
will get five different opinions so I
will add the sixth opinion uh to all of
those so let's try to explore together
what we mean by event driven what we
mean by reactive what workflows are and
what uh sagas are
so
to start this out to start the whole
journey how did we get there and why is
uh event driven why is reactive why is
that all the hype
we start where we usually start
um when we talk about modern software
and that is we talk about well it all
started with the monolith so our
applications were monolithic now there
were one cohesive unit but that didn't
mean that our applications were one big
ball of mud right so we talk a lot about
um the modular monolith the monolith was
already
composed of individual modules now at
some point in time
we ran into limitations we ran into
technical limitations and we ran into
organizational limitations which
um motivated us motivated a lot of us to
take the
um monolith and break it apart
so
however
the application was one coherent
application and it has to be one
coherent application again it is not
just some
set of services some set of
microservices from the user's
perspective it is still one coherent
application so what we decomposed must
now be recomposed so we still have to
have one coherent unit one coherent
application and the question is
how do we compose and what do we compose
because if we look at this
um this illustration
it has a structural aspect to it it is a
structural properties we look at the
illustration of the structure of a
system however we are often interested
in the in the behavior of a system right
it's a it's a dynamic system a dynamic
system shows Behavior so we are
interested in processes
um when we decompose a monolithic
application into microservices we now
also decompose
the individual processes
not only across time that is a defining
characteristic about a process to begin
with that it takes a certain amount of
time now we also decompose it spatially
so we have decomposed temporarily and
spatially
so
our previously
coherent execution is now composed of
multiple executions
and
something that we can
see that is a a
characteristic of
of the individual individual executions
in our system is that at the very top
will be usually see as a top what we
usually see is the root of the behavior
our
our business process
it has a coordination aspect to it and
the further we go down it has an
execution aspect to it that is what we
call what we talk about in temporal all
the time workflows right so you have
workflows and you have activities
workflows are the
coordination of your system the
activities are the execution
so when you look at the coordination
aspect then usually you do not have any
side effects in the in the system and
the further you go down the further you
come down to the
um
to the atomic steps in the system the
more you have side effects side effects
could be something is writing to a
database something is uh writing to
um a message queue something is sending
an email these are the actual side
effects and at the top we have the
coordination
now
that also lines up with our notion of
what is long-lived and what is
short-lived
and uh long lift is a
they are difficult a flawed term because
it is not necessarily the case that this
is actually a long execution right for
some of us long-lift is a mere minute
others long lift is an hour could be a
day it could be a week a month year
years so what is long lived to me maybe
something else that what is long-lived
to you so what is the defining
characteristic of uh long lift
right that is usually that our processes
at the at the very top these long-lived
processes they don't have an inherent
time limit
and uh they also shell execute as if in
the absence of failure so typically I do
not retry at that level what does that
even mean to retry something at a at a
coordination level let's say I have a
subscription workflow and that
subscription workflow
um
runs for once every month for example
um let's take a Netflix membership that
has inherently no time limit nobody is
going to take my Netflix account from me
anytime soon so inherently that does not
have a time limit yet happens once uh a
month when I when I renew my
subscription what does that mean when I
signed up I don't know 2007 when I
signed up and that fails and I retry am
I going to go back to 2007 that doesn't
even make sense right so on this level
on the coordination level and the long
lived level we do not have inherent time
limits and we must execute as if in the
absence of failure
now when we come down when we come down
to the to the
um execution aspect of things that's a
little different that is where
individual things actually do map to
function executions individual function
executions function executions have a
time limit function executions may
actually fail this is where uh in order
to avoid the time limits I need to break
up my functions in actual short lift
functions or my executions in
short-lived functions and if something
happens there if they go wrong right if
the underlying resource ceases to exist
and therefore my function execution
ceases to exist that is where retries
come into play I can totally retry on on
that level retrying writing to the
database retrying writing to a message
queue or retrying sending an email
hopefully not too many times
so we we have this in summer we have
this uh this um at least two levels of
uh different processes the ones that
have more of a coordination aspect that
coordinate the executions the ones that
are more long-lived that coordinate the
executions of the more
short-lived ones so the question arises
how do we actually Implement that that
is our question on the on the bottom uh
things where we have executions and
where we have short-lived We have
basically no question we have figured
that out long ago we can map those
executions to Mayor function executions
but how do we implement
the long lift or the long left
coordinating executions that is a
um different question and there we have
two I would argue at least two
mainstream Notions how should we do this
and uh the two competing ideas here are
around
um orchestration and around choreography
and just like with
um event driven itself which we actually
still did not answer yet what is event
driven there is lots of
um
lots of questions and explanations what
actually is orchestration and what
actually is choreography so let's look
into that a little bit
so for orchestration
I just want to point out if you look at
this illustration the illustration alone
depicts a process right it depicts a
behavior step one step two step three
that's going to be interesting once we
compare that to choreography so just
keep that in mind that here the
illustration depicts a process
so let's
um
just list a few of the common terms that
are associated with orchestration so
when we think orchestration we often
think command based we think request
response right something is driving and
driving that basically means there is a
very explicit control flow
it is very direct so the coordinator
calls the executor called the first
executor courses second calls the Third
oftentimes we associate orchestration
with intra domain if anybody is into
into domain uh driven development to
mind-driven design we say oh yeah
orchestration is cool yeah you can do
that intra-domain but don't do it into
domain do not do it across
um across Services stay in your domain
when you do it and why are we saying
that because we associate orchestration
with
um
High coupling
is that fair is that fair to do
keep that in mind is that fair to do
okay before we answer that question
let's go into choreography so so if you
look at this illustration that is
different this illustration does not
depict Behavior this illustration
depicts the structure of the system
where you have something like an event
bus in the in the center and Individual
Services talk to the event bus read to
them read from them and pass right to
the event bus now what do we usually
associate with orchestration
with orchestration we like to think
orchestration is event-based
coordination so in that sense that is
already the first hint that we say Okay
event driven systems are usually
orchestrated systems there is something
to that so but what else do we mean when
we say well it is event based
coordination
event-based coordination hints to an
implicit control flow not an explicit
control flow I don't have a
requester and I don't have a request the
response now I raise an event and I
listen to an event so in that sense the
control flow is indirect so I actually
do not have explicit behavior in the
system the behavior of the system
emerges that is something that we should
also keep in mind
and now the notion is event based that
is really cool for interdomain you want
to use event-based coordination to
coordinate
um
interdomain you to coordinate across
Services why because
orchestration leads to loose coupling
okay that I would argue is the common
wisdom now again
um you can ask uh three different people
and you will get five different opinions
but I think most of what we said so far
is
um fairly agreeable but I want to
challenge that notion and say that
um that is actually not correct
um
neither orchestration nor
choreography thank you all
that's unfortunate
oh that's unfortunate okay sorry for
that copy paste
that shall say choreography thank you
so and uh we will immediately move on
from that you know
meh okay but it's a very important point
but luckily we have a summary slide that
is actually correct okay good good so in
summary we have the long-lived uh um we
need we need long-lived coordination how
can we Implement that we can implement
it either via orchestration or we can
implement it via choreography
orchestration is command-based
orchestration is imperative
orchestration is what we think of as
tightly coupled now choreography we
think is event-based choreography is
declarative and for whatever reason we
think that that is actually Loosely
coupled but I want to challenge that
notion just because something is command
based does not mean that it is tightly
coupled and just because something is
event based does not mean that it is
Loosely coupled sometimes actually the
opposite
true
by the way my favorite definition and we
will see that in action in just a moment
is what is actually imperative what is
declarative we hear that a lot right so
it's like if anybody ever hears uh the
term kubernetes about two seconds later
you're gonna hear that it's a
declarative system what does it even
mean so my favorite definition of
imperative is that
um
imperative system or an inter an
imperative program is a sequence of
instructions there is a declarative
system is a set of instructions it does
not specify a certain flow
now let's look at that as an example we
want to implement a flow so on the top
we still have the coordination we want
to implement the flow
and that flow is made up of three
individual executions a b and c now
again the coordination
the coordination happens at the top and
the execution happens at the bottom so A
B and C are the ones that actually
execute your side effects so a b and c
is what we are after
and now there is an um
interesting notion of equivalence in the
in the former former semantic Community
there is a very strong notion of
equivalence that is called uh by
simulation but
um in a general sense equivalence just
means that hey however we make sure that
we call a then we call B and then we
call C
however we do that one way is completely
equivalent to the other way
but they may actually differ in the
developer experience let's look at one
way I would argue anybody here would say
okay this is
as imperative as it gets I call a i call
B I call C
all right let's click show of hands who
thinks this is orchestration
okay who thinks this is choreography
okay
this is in the classic definition closer
to orchestration
because it is command-based the command
is called a Colby colesi it's direct it
has a direct
um
it's an explicit control flow Direct
but let's look at the different
implementation one that is equivalent
because it also calls A and B and C in
that order
whoa now this is already like a whole
different word and there we have an
event handler we have one event handler
that event handler can listen to
um
for a different event flow requested
that is the invocation of the flow
a returned B returned and C returned
okay all of this is already pretty
strange to me so what we gonna do the
very first line says well if we see an
event flow requested we trigger an event
a requested so apparently we have an
event handler somewhere that actually
executes our execution reacts to a
requested and then triggers a returned
well what do we do if we get a returned
well look at that we have uh we have an
event handler or I'm sorry we have a
section in our event handler that
um reacts to a returned and triggers P
requested and so on and so forth now
it's getting a little boring so we do
not need to go through that but as we
see this is definitely a
equivalent implementation but it's very
different that is actually declarative
as there is no sequence it's just a set
of instructions it's an imperative
control flow the behavior of the system
emerges at runtime it depends on the
sequence of events that and the event
history that we see one moment it
depends on the sequence of events and
the event history that we see and
um the the behavior unlike in the
previous example the behavior of the
system will come to life as the system
moves uh through its lifetime let's look
at one more example that is entirely
equivalent here we don't have one event
handler we have multiple event handlers
but it's basically the same idea they
are just not folded into one they're
folded into many flow requested which
will trigger an a requested then a
returned which will trigger a b
requested and so on and so forth
so
um when you when you look at when you
look at the second and the third example
but since the first example was
orchestration the second and the third
example already hints to
event-based choreography in fact the
previous one where we had one event
handler
will remind us about the Saga pattern
and the second one where we have
multiple event handlers these are
typically not called sagas as there are
more one steps they are just called
event handlers so here we have an event
based system and all three
implementations are equivalent since
they are calling a b and c in the same
order yet I would argue that the
developer experience
when you have to implement that as a as
an as an actual system differs quite a
lot
and in order to make all of this a
little more graspable because I do have
a tendency to speak in like very
abstract terms so I actually do have an
example
and I could actually use a double shot
right now I'm not entirely sure about
all of you but it's one of my favorite
examples and that is uh Amazon dash
button unfortunately that one is
discontinued but I always thought it's
pretty cool because all you have to do
is you push the button and then the
button will
um order in this case a double shot no
other interaction needed so let's see
how we could Implement that both as a
classic orchestration example and as a
choreography example
okay let's take this business process so
um when we implement the dash button we
usually or I want to argue Amazon at
that point had the chance to already
rely on a huge set of services there was
the payment service was already
implemented in inventory Service
shipping service so we can rely on these
Services already and the only things we
were interested in here now is
the process payment and the refund
payment the process item and the restock
items and the ship items
okay and we want to implement this flow
the business process the coordination
that when I push the button that we move
through the individual stages we get the
payment
we get the item ready and we ship the
item
so our Pro yes it's like our process
very straightforward so again process
payment process item ship the item so
how can we actually make that happen
one thing that is also very important is
since we do not have
um transactions in in these scenarios
because our business processes are
composed of individual steps and
typically transactions cannot outlive
the execution steps unless you have
distributed application distributed
transactions which are usually not
available to us we need to deal with
failure so how do we deal with failure
usually with uh compensation now
oftentimes we talk about compensation in
the context of event-based systems and
in the context of sagas specifically but
compensation is not specific to
event-based or sagas anywhere where I do
not have
a transaction context that lives as long
as my coordination but only as long as
the individual executions I need to deal
with compensation to basically roll back
the changes that I already did in case
of my business process
um failing in the middle
all right let's look at an event-based
system let's look at what we need to do
when we want to coordinate
the long-lift execution via events so
the first one we typically have what we
call a command that is how the user
kicks off the process that is when I
push the button then we have a command
place order so that command goes to for
example the checkout service and the
checkout service then translates that
command into an event order placed
now the payment service is wired up so
that nobody is actually calling the
payment service I'm just listening I'm
just listening to the uh to that event
order placed from there on the payment
service will go ahead and collect the
payment
and then raise an event that says
payment received well from there on we
are basically just going through the
chain the behavior of our business
process emerges the inventory listens to
payment received
um we'll prepare the items and or
process the items and then emit the
event items per test and then the
shipment service listens to that event
and eventually uh when the when the
shipment is on its way
trigger the event order shift
okay so far so good for this particular
business process that event chain
straightforward
is it so is it actually that
straightforward so if I the order placed
event was a good chance the order place
event has all of the informations about
the order all of the informations about
the order may actually mean that the
event is self-contained
um from the point of view of the payment
service all information
that I need about making the payment
happen may actually be in the order
placed event okay so then the payment
um
the the payment service raises the
payment received event
now the inventory service needs to make
sure that we process the items
will the payment received event contain
all of the information
including the list of items that we are
actually now that we need to prepare
maybe so maybe in the system that you
designed all of that information is
actually available but maybe it is not
maybe we need to listen to more than one
event maybe the inventory service
actually needs to listen to order placed
and uh payment received in order to get
enough information to do what the
inventory service needs to do and that
is probably also true for the shipment
because the event
items processed may not contain the
information letting you know where the
shipment needs to go so that obviously
already complicates our event chain
quite a bit and we are oddly dependent
in different services on different
amounts of on different types of events
now you could of course argue and say
well in that case the events do not
contain all the information maybe the
events just contain the information
where I get more information from but
now we have to throw in a few more
databases and access to databases and is
it really the best idea for the
inventory service to then call out to
the check out service and ask for more
information right we already see that
this uh this idea that we had that
event-based system makes for loose
coupling makes it uh makes it uh fairly
flexible is already being challenged a
bit okay
if you look at the at the orchestration
flow
that is somewhat different the process
is it's very direct it's command based
the process is uh completely reflected
in that sequence
process item process payment and ship
item especially if these individual
individual steps we could in this is a
temporal conference so we can think of
these individual steps as for example
child workflows
so very well contained one other aspect
that you're seeing here is actually
failure handling
I try to get failure handling into the
into the previous picture and I failed
miserably that already made it so
complicated that I didn't want to walk
anybody through that so but if you look
at the at the compensation Logic on this
level that is actually everything is
very straightforward
so I don't think there is much we can
talk about here
but let's do a twist yeah because I mean
everything has to have turns and twists
every good story you know so let's throw
in a Twist so remember the business the
original business process was we process
the payment we process the item and then
we ship the items all right our
um Market team or cast customer
satisfaction team
figured out you know what most of the
time we get the money anyways all right
so let's make sure we process the items
immediately as soon as we push the
button to make sure we get these items
out the door as fast as possible so now
we're switching up our business process
to process item process payment ship
items okay what does it do to our event
chain
remember that was our event chain we
didn't exactly know if the inventory
service and the shipment service
listened to order placed but let's make
it pretty simple and argue that they
didn't right okay so we had the uh event
uh driven
um system over here we were arguing that
it was all fairly flexible and fairly
Loosely coupled let's see what happens
all right so we need to break up this
chain right so we need to alter the
emergent behavior in order to alter the
emergent Behavior we need to now start
to listen to different events so the
payment service cannot listen to the
older place no more and the inventory
service cannot listen to the payment
received anymore instead the inventory
service now needs to be changed so that
it listens to a different event so we
need to reach to a different service
wire it up differently so that now the
inventory service listens to order
placed
okay
you good
that was unexpected
so we have the inventory service the
inventory Service uh still raises uh
items processed however the shipment
service cannot listen to items processed
anymore that is a little bit premature
first the payment service needs to
listen to
um to the items processed event and now
in order to complete the event chain
and the shipment service now listens to
the payment received event
all right
one flip
we'll change the order of two steps
we basically touched each and every
component of the system
let's see what that does to our
orchestration based workflow
previous
the end
because we have an explicit
an explicit flow
all we have to do is actually change the
number of steps around and of course
also change the components the
compensating actions but the changes
here are actually fairly innocent not
much happened right
so
again
I did not draw this out because I gave
up I didn't want to talk anybody through
that but let's do this what if we had a
preferred customer segment and a regular
customer segment the preferred customers
we do not wait for the payment we
immediately process the items and ship
the items because we for our preferred
customers we assume that the payment
will go through later however regular
customers we want for regular customers
to First collect the payment then
um
process items and ship the items so
anybody can think of how that event
chain or event mesh or event mess may
look like but I didn't want to draw it
out but if you want to think about how
that's going to look like in an
imperative program in a workflow there
is uh one if then a statement that
should actually take care of your issue
all right and now
let's look at the let's look at the last
uh the last change to the business
process
in this change uh we are not changing
the in this business process we're not
changing the sequence all we want to do
is let's send out emails right because
all of us want to be in the loop of what
happens with our with our business
process so here we just change this up
and after each and every step we send a
confirmation email to our user that we
got the payment the items are processed
and the items are shipped now with the
tracking code
okay
so here once again we have our simple
original event chain
and we throw in a notification service
that notification service is the one
that sends the emails and that
notification service in our situation
needs to listen to three events the
payment received event the items
processed event the order shipped event
okay
so the payment service
depends on I'm sorry the the email
sending service depends on three events
let's keep that in mind
okay for our business process once again
that is fairly straightforward
um I think we can all anticipate what's
going to happen we throw in I took out
the failure code so it's not that much
we throw in a few statements we throw in
send email in that we Supply the
arguments because we are command based
that is a caller supplies the arguments
to the Kohli and here we have the
payment process template that we want
the email service to use throw in a bag
of data render the template send it out
the same is true for items process
template
and
um itemship template
now
how does that actually look like
so if I have an order workflow and I
want to send three different emails
I introduced one more dependency no
question about that
so
the order workflow now depends on the
send email action and the order workflow
is the one that is responsible to
provide the arguments to the send email
action
the send email action is not at all
dependent on the order workflow all at
once is a template or
the information where it can get and
download the template and data for
example hashmap in order to be able to
render the email and then send it to the
user
but how does that look like in uh in
choreography in an event driven so we
have one service you would think one
fairly independent Standalone service
send email
that now needs to listen to three
different events it also needs to know
how to extract the information that it
needs to send the email from three
different events that have absolutely
nothing to do with each other so there
is probably nothing you can reuse and
there is no no I no common idea of how
to get a template
for one of these events so a very
standalone-ish service actually has a
dependency is coupled to three different
events
so I mean baby Yoda had to make an
appearance and therefore also the
Mandalorian so
um in uh summary event driven reactive
applications with temporals workflows
versus sagas the epic showdown
what was my takeaway so typically we
talk about
orchestration versus choreography
but as we saw there is an equivalence
between orchestration and choreography
as long as either the orchestrated or
the choreographed implementation of your
business process
implements your business process there
is no difference on the
there is no technical difference there's
only a difference in the developer
experience now in the developer
experience we typically say that
orchestration comes with
imperative Style
tight coupling we say that it is
inflexible and we think that
choreography it comes with
um
event-based coordination it is very
flexible it comes Loosely coupled but if
you look at these examples this is two
um too narrow of a statement or two
broad of a statement I would argue that
for many times orchestration will
actually give you the better developer
experience because it is fairly easy to
reason about imperative systems and it's
also fairly easy to change and evolve
imperative systems while as we saw in
this particular example
event based systems sagas where we have
implicit control flow and the behavior
of the system emerges it is a fairly
hard to reason about the system as a
whole there is no single point no single
play spray could look and understand the
behavior of the system and changing the
system and the evolution of the system
is also fairly challenging and the idea
that just because we have event-based
systems we have a very loose coupling
can also be challenged with examples
very simple innocent looking examples
like introducing sending an email after
each and every step
and with that thank you very much we did
we did finish this presentation just a
little bit ahead of time so in case
anybody has any questions or anybody has
any uh comments I am very happy to try
to answer them
please
that diagram change if after each
like microservice microservices since
two events
quarter completed event I know send
email is not
comparative
that's
so the the question is uh can we uh can
we actually find a work around can we
work around that so for example if we
wanted to send email after each and
every step why don't we have the payment
service and the inventory service and
the shipment service raise an additional
event and that event could that event
has more of a command quality where we
say send email
and has more of a command quality where
we say
um send email
um and I would argue that this is where
we get into the uh into the
situation where we started off and that
is actually that happens a lot we
started off
um with this notion oh we're going to be
purely event driven right and then we
see where there are situations where
this event-driven notion falls apart and
that is where we then also enter okay
let's enter commands into our system
instead of one event especially like a
domain event let's also raise other
events or let's uh raise commands and in
that case I would argue eventually you
are worse off you started with a modular
monolith which was actually fairly easy
to maintain and evolve and change
compared to now one uh big distributed
ball of mud where you basically just
raise wildly race events and commands
and
um crisscross listen to them but yes
it's a very it's a very common uh it's a
it's a very common pattern
oh sorry
just uh thinking about the benefits of
orchestration over choreography and in
some it seems like there's some
situations where orchestration is
Superior
what are the situations where
choreography is superior and I'm kind of
imagining some hybrid situation where
the more densely coupled parts of the
system are using orchestration and then
between I guess it's like the
inter-domain interdomain can you say
something about where where choreography
is more valuable
um let me put it this way I just like I
I uh rather not make a general statement
um about that but what I am very very
often that is also what we were looking
at a lot today is where you have
orchestration in Disguise of
choreography right so it's like in in
choreography that is very often a
request response driven right no I'm
sorry in orchestration that is very
often request response driven
um when you see
um when you see orcas when you see
choreography chains that actually just
reflect requests and responses right but
then you give it a fancy name like
um I don't know payment requested is the
event and then payment process is the
next event that is basically the request
comes in and the response comes back
right and for me that is all
orchestration in Disguise of
choreography and for that you get
basically all of the drawbacks and none
of the rewards so that is where that is
where I would make a more general
statement but
um
I would rather not make two general
statements about choreography in general
please
thank you so question is what is the
best strategy in your opinion to
associate
uh related events and group them uh so
let's say a particular side effect
depends on more than one event being
completed how do you make sure that it
only accounts for the ones that are
related to each other before it fires
and also ensures that all the relevant
events of a particular event group
have been
emitted before that action in a service
is executed
that is a that is an excellent question
that would actually make each and every
single example of of this presentation
even more painful when it comes to when
it comes to
um choreography so there is
um there is a a fairly cool Saga
tutorial out there and I will share the
links later on Temple slack on the water
cooler if you Google for
in service bus and sagas they have a
pretty cool example out there and
um
in in they they have a they have a
particular solution to their problem
when you do event correlation first when
you look at the individual events you
actually have to make sure that you find
the correct instance of the business
process right because order one two
three is completely different from order
two three four so first off you need to
find the right order of the business
process then second you actually need
sometimes you need to wait for multiple
events this is where sagas get more
complicated and you definitely have to
throw in
State handling now in that case when
that Saga gets an event that Saga needs
to remember that it already got event
one but not event two or if it gets even
two then it must remember that it got
even two not event one and then when it
gets the other event then it triggers uh
some behavior and with that the explicit
State machine that you need to manage
becomes way way way harder whereas that
step machine you do not necessarily
explicitly have to manage if you use
imperative imperative code if you use
orchestration because in an imperative
in an imperative system the sequence of
events you actually have an implicit
State machine right and the state is
just the program counter and our our
entire runtime manages that for us
of course sometimes you do have to
coordinate a little bit in the case of
uh temporal for example sometimes you do
have to be able to react to signals and
also wait for multiple signals but
because of the routing of tempura
at least you do not have to worry about
the fact that the signals find the right
receiver
please
so first of all thank you very much it's
really you have touched on some very
interesting kind of topic areas here so
I'm curious too and wondering what your
comment is right about like compensation
mechanism in Saga I mean does it
actually break you know stateless type
of implementation especially when we're
talking about Cloud native is supposed
to be all stateless and then you're
doing Saga you need to worry about
compensation then you have to remember
the state and all these things so
compensation is so compensation isn't is
an interesting topic for uh many people
um compensation is a defining criteria
of uh The Saga pattern I actually argue
that compensation is not a defining
criteria of The Saga pattern
um but it is a very common uh very
common occurrence of the of the Saga and
you are entirely correct so even if you
manage to implement a stateless Saga as
soon as it comes to compensation you
probably have to remember steps that you
already have taken right in order to be
able then to call compensating actions
on the steps that you already have taken
so
um but most of the time business
processes are not stateless to begin
with
most of the time business processes do
carry state so when it comes to
compensation in sagas I would argue that
only in when you get really really lucky
yeah did you not already have to worry
about State before you uh before you
added compensation only if you got
really really lucky but
um the state machine of rolling back
just in in sagas explicitly managing
that state machine just became very very
hard because if you look at our
imperative code if you look at for
example Java and you look at the try
catch block and nested try catch blocks
that control flow primitive is very very
powerful that resulting State machine
is actually very difficult to implement
by hand and in case of saga that's
exactly what you have to do
any other questions
please
so it seems to me that even driven model
can make it easy to do things in
parallel for example if you take your
dash button
event driven model shipping service so
far you could do payment and item
processing in parallel and then shipping
could listen for both and when both
happen then you ship the item right but
if it's a imperative model then you have
to do in sequence or you you create some
kind of threads or go routines or
whatever and then you have to wait for
both which becomes more complicated
so um I would I would argue that in the
case of uh choreography where you kick
off multiple sub-processes that are
truly uncoordinated multiple Pro
sub-processes that are completely
independent of each other multiple
processes that are truly concurrent
right then that can actually work if you
however have a branch out so basically a
fork and join pattern if at any point in
time you need to coordinate these sub
processes again
then you do have
you do have the problem where you
actually once again have to wait for
multiple events and coordinate and
remember what events you already
um body events you already saw and which
events you didn't see whereas if you
have an imperative style like
um Java or go that have
um the the concurrency Primitives
basically baked in or as available as a
library
um I would argue that is from a
developer experience you still haven't
have an uh easier choice
I think we have time for one more
question if there is one
okay if there is not then I think we
just reached the conclusion of the very
first day of
Temple is Inaugural developer conference
replay it was an absolute pleasure to
have everybody here I hope you enjoyed
it uh justice much as we did it was
absolutely fantastic to see everybody in
person it was a
great turnout we did not expect to have
uh this many people here on day one we
are super excited
that you all came and joined us and we
are very much looking forward to seeing
you again tomorrow for the main event
thank you very much